multiple departments at stanford and my
background is
actually in math and then i got a phd in
statistics
without any biology
but
after you know kind of functioning
functioning as a statistician for quite
a while i realized that the biological
universe was
incredibly fascinating to me and i
really wanted to make a career
transition which i did about 15 years
ago
um i was really especially motivated by
two biological problems which i really
at the time only understood from a lay
perspective and they were ones that i'm
sure you are all
aware of and very interested in as well
one of them being cancer and the other
being viral infections
and so
i have
when i actually started work as a
computational biologist without really
knowing anything i worked in the field
of cancer genomics right at the time
that sea one thing was beginning to be
available
and
one of the projects that i worked on was
a project around trying to discover gene
fusions in cancer and this was suggested
by my mentor
pat brown
and the reason that he suggested it
was um
one of the defining features of cancer
genomes is actually
their incredible genomic instability at
the level of chromosomes and you can see
that on the
left here with an incredibly aneuploid
chromosome cytology from a tumor cell of
a glioblastoma
and this is very typical of of cancer
cells okay they don't have
normal chromosomal configurations
so
still
we're a lot of focus is on
studying cancer at the point of
uh sorry at the level of point mutations
where we try to find individual single
nucleotide variation okay
one of the fascinating outcomes of the
sequencing revolution has been that
we've actually found that normal
epithelial and normal
cells in your body have the identical
mutations in driver genes
that cancer cells do okay so
there's a real suggestion that genomic
rearrangements define and drive cancer
another um
huge
kind of i don't know biological problem
which i'm i'm i know that everyone is
also familiar with now especially in the
era of stars cove two
is that viruses are an incredible threat
to human health
um today because of vaccines we probably
we
we're at a moment in history where we
have an approximate handle on
being able to control them
throughout history uh they have been
incredibly deadly okay so
these are two examples of
biological problems that genomics
really
wants to tackle and
have incredible impact
okay so
is there a common theme
in terms of what what our field as
computational biologists could
contribute to understanding cancer and
understanding viral biology and
evolution okay and so what i want to
really tell you about for the rest of
the talk is
um a different way of thinking about
these problems than
the one that we typically
the approach that we typically take as a
field okay so
today we have better and better compute
we have more and more storage and
we are still as a field generally trying
to keep pace
with
the reference genomes of cancers and
viruses among and among other species
that we attempt to sequence and
understand
okay
and we are still
um
building
knowledge towards the first incredible
um advance in computational biology
which was the sequencing of the human
genome more than 20 years ago we now
appreciate that it is a sequence of a
single human genome
and the more and more we
attempt to expand the knowledge of the
human genome to
diverse populations
the more we understand that it is
necessarily incomplete okay this is for
this is a quick example from a recent
study
where there were just you know about 100
or so african-american individual
african african individual thousand
african
individuals that were sequenced um and
they found more than 300 megabases of
missing dna in genes
okay
in cancers this is especially
um you know the the incompleteness of
the reference genome is especially
apparent the kind of crazy chromosomal
configurations that i showed you in one
of the earliest slides
we now understand some of the mechanisms
that are underlie this and
it's called chromothrypsis
literally what happens is dna can get
shattered and rearranged almost like you
know a combinatorial rearrangement of
puzzle pieces
you can see
that the resulting chromosomes really
have no relationship to the human
reference genome
beyond cancers
the scale of the living world
means that it is really going basically
impossible to store reference genomes
there are more than 10 to the 30th
bacteria on earth
more viruses
in the plant kingdom
there is an incredible amount of
structural variation and although we
still attempt to to assemble reference
genomes
they're almost certainly incomplete
okay
so i think these are biological strong
biological reasons to try to avoid
references but are there also
statistical ones
and i would say as a statistician yes
what after even if you had a perfect
reference genome
we know that reference genomes are
littered with repetitive elements
and because of that
alignment algorithms
have to
they're cut they become complicated
multi-step
procedures um
this is
this is an example of um a workflow
for a typical alignment procedure
um
you know they're they're very
complicated they have to rely on
some sometimes to randomize heuristics
in order to make the search
efficient
um and for all of these reasons it is
difficult or impossible to obtain valid
p-values at the end of
you know taking data that has been run
through an aligner
okay so
um
i'd like to just ask what why do we use
references i mean alignments are useful
but why are we actually using them
okay and i would say one of the major
reasons
that we use reference genomes
is
as a guide post to the fundamental
scientific
step which is inference
of differences between conditions so
for example in cancer we might want to
align to a reference genome so that we
can
then perform statistical inference
on what is different about the cancer
versus the normal
or in a
microbiome we might want to perform
inference on what is different after you
have been treated with antibiotics or
not
in the case of plant genomics we might
want to perform inference on whether
this crop variety is better resistant to
drought or makes better fruit
okay so
that's a really
um powerful
kind of uh
reference genomes enable this kind of
scientific inference
which is great
but they have all these limitations that
i started the talk with so the question
is could we bypass reference genomes
and still
provid provide and obtain the
statistical inference that we eventually
want to have which is you know
fundamental okay so for the rest of the
talk what i'll tell you about is our
our work which i think is a very strong
first step in this direction
and it derives from formulating a
probabilistic model directly
so that we can
perform statistical inference on
the data that we observe from sequencing
k-mers or fastq files without going
through this intermediate process of
alignment
okay
and
um
in order to give some intuition for what
we're going to do i'd like you to
consider
that
there are a variety of different
biological problems from cancer genomics
to viral
variants that are emerging
to
mobilization of dna or infection of
phages into bacteria
that are that have a shared biological
feature
and that feature is also shared
in um by rna splicing
and that's an example that i'll talk
about in a little bit
um that feature is that sequences
in these um
when we are interested in the
differential conditions between for
example a phage integrating into a
bacteria versus not there's a shared
biological feature
which i will call sequence
diversification
and that is the local sequence context
in the genome with and without the phage
is different so if you're you see a
sequence here and you have the phage the
sequence near it is going to be
different than
the sequence without it
okay
um
so there are many many examples which i
will turn to later that fit into this
probabilistic formulation
from microbial evolution to spatial
genomics cancer genomics and more
okay
um
so the current approaches to
attacking the problems that i described
to you in the in the previous
slide
all follow essentially the same workflow
of taking fastq files aligning them
with throwing out unaligned reads that
don't match the genome
and then performing some kind of
statistical inference
and they have
shortcomings which include they're being
fragmented in that you have to
pre-specify a specific pipeline and
algorithm to run
they're time-consuming we know that
alignment is computationally intensive
and they have unknown sources of errors
okay so
i'm now going to tell you about
nomad which is a reference free and
sensitive approach to direct statistical
inference on k-mers and this is the work
of um two tremendously power um talented
people it's really a team and an
incredible team effort caitlyn chang and
tabor bahra i think they might both be
here um as well as vania zeludev
okay so
like i said we are going to be really
treating
genomic inference as a direct
statistical
procedure on sequencing data raw
sequencing data
and
bypassing alignment completely
so while i could
talk about the math later
and i would love to i'm pretty much
going to just share this high level view
of what i mean by sequence
diversification
so consider a problem like rna splicing
which falls into this category of
attempting to do inference directly on
sequencing raw sequencing reads
the question is we have two samples
sample one might be cell type one and
symbol two cell type two
sample one
um predominantly splices exon one to
exon three where i assemble two
to exon two
okay so i've given an example
oh sorry okay so
sample one and two are obviously
switched at the top here sorry
um but i've given you an example
of
the configuration of the exon splicing
at the bottom
and an
example sequence that might be
underlying this toy kind of box plot
so
what what is the kind of statistical or
probabilistic model underlying this
difference it is that if we observe a
sequence s at the beginning of this read
or rna transcript
the probability of seeing
t another
subsequent
some fixed distance downstream of s
has is a function of the sample identity
okay so
it is sample specific this probability
distribution
and that's really the key
kind of um high level
idea that we're going to be using to to
work with okay so what do we do
in this algorithm nomad
okay
we are going to be processing raw
sequencing reads
and you can think of it in the simplest
case of course we are scaling this as
i'll tell you about um but just in the
case of two reads we we get a single
k-mer
um or you know sequence from sample one
another sequence from sample two
we catalog their k-mer compositions in
the following way we
look for
the first part of the sequence in sample
one it's going to be aaa in this toy
example in these two samples
and we then
build a contingency table
very simple basic statistical object
which has
two different subsequences target one
and target two
because those uh
these subsequences are the ones that
follow
l nucleotides away from that first
subsequence then we
do this for each sample we catalog the
counts
and we perform some statistical
procedures that have that provide closed
form valid p-values
without any kind of resampling needed
and this is very important because it
allows this algorithm to be incredibly
efficient
okay so compared to existing methods
what nomads workflow is it takes in the
raw fastq files it sorts them and
kind of parses them into contingency
tables
it performs valid statistical inference
incredibly fat and you know incredibly
quickly
and then
it does post facto inference or for
interpretation so sorry when i mean
inference i mean human kind of
interpretation
and it has allowed us to
um
in the same algorithm as i'll tell you
about now
detect alternative splice variants
more powerfully than state of the art
vdj recombination which is the basis of
how antibodies and t cells are generated
viral strain of variation and other
examples again that i don't have time to
tell you about
um okay so
i'm going to give a snapshot of the
results
um
what i will tell you about derived from
application of the identical algorithm
and its default parameter regime so
there is no there are of course lots of
parameters that we can change for
example k-mer length and other things
but everything was just run kind of in
default mode
okay so i'll tell you a little bit about
sars cove 2
and human single cell rna seq data i
don't think i'll have time to tell you
about lemurs okay so
um you know sars cove 2 is obviously an
incredibly
serious public health threat and
today
i don't know if people
really remember how omicron was first
identified in south africa it was
identified clinically it was not first
identified genomically
clinicians realized that there was an
uptick in cases and then they went
um into the sequencing surveillance data
that they had performed
and had to kind of combine
alignment-based procedures and manual
curation to discover the variant
okay so we just grabbed
the
sequencing data from about 70 patients
in south africa
in that first genomic
study that they that
clinicians used to characterize the
omicron variant and we ran nomad which
is the algorithm that i talked to you
about
we
we also have a control
for nomad which for time reasons i won't
go into
and one of the really exciting things to
us was that nomad identified k-mers
that were in
highly enriched in being
proximate to the known omicron variant
without any knowledge of the sars cov2
genome without any knowledge of the
omicron variants okay so
again we are running a statistical
algorithm on raw sequencing
reads from patients
and yeah okay five minutes yeah
inferring exactly where
basically trying to infer which k-mers
are
sample specifically diverse
so here's an example of a sequence that
nomad identified we
after you know after
the nomad calls we sought to interpret
it we aligned it to the
stars genome and it aligns
immediately upstream as would be
expected if if this algorithm were
performing as we wanted it to
before a set of
omicron specific mutations
okay
here's another way that we can run nomad
it doesn't require any reference genome
and so for that reason while we can take
the k-mers that are output by it and
align them to reference genomes we don't
have to we can actually go directly to
in
an in-silico
translation of these k-mers to predict
protein fragments that we can then align
to databases we call this in silico
translation
we perform
we perform this on
another data set and um i guess the
slide got cut off so
we
by ordering the enrichment of the
protein domains in nomad compared to
other um
the controls
we identified that the spike protein
totally de novo had the highest
mutational burden
okay
the last minute or two i'm going to give
you a final snapshot of
nomad's application to human single cell
biology
and one of the major mysteries of the
human genome and one that has been very
difficult to study with
alignment-based procedures is why
there are gene duplications and whether
they
have functional differences okay here's
an example of a gene that has this
feature my l12 which has 95 amino acid
sorry 95
nucleotide
um
similarity between two homologs of the
gene that are positioned immediately
next to each other on the human genome
alignment based approaches simply cannot
distinguish which of these two isoforms
are
expressed and nomad is able to do this
um in it basically able to resolve cell
type specific
expression differences of these two
isoforms
um
without any kind of guidance or training
and i think really opens the door to a
huge amount of new biology for example
to study
human immunology
i think for time reasons i'm going to
skip this but the major
histocompatibility complex is a gene
locus that is one of the most important
for protecting our bodies against cancer
and viruses
but has large numbers of homologs that
make alignment-based approaches
essentially unable to resolve haplotypes
efficiently
okay so
in summary
there are really myriad
applications of of nomad analysis in the
biological realm and um i think one of
the most
important to me is
uh an implication for health disparities
so
you know the human reference genome was
built from a caucasian individual and
even though we are as a field attempting
to rectify that situation in reality the
vast majority of sequence genomes come
from a certain um subset of individuals
an advantage of going completely
reference free is that you have you are
you know have no bias
towards
finding variants that are associated
with diseases based on what we know
about
reference genomes from
at least in the u.s caucasian
individuals
um
we are about to um
you know
extend this algorithm to be very
versatile and work with 10x genomics it
already works really well with
smartseek2
and there are just myriad
applications here
to to viruses to microbes and other
other applications um from the
statistical side
there we you know we have one
statistical approach that we published
in this this all work this
all this work by the way is published on
the bio archive
um
but
there are many important and open
statistical problems that this work
provokes and we're very excited on
working on them
um and so i would like to thank everyone
that has contributed to this work
and the funding agencies
sure so
it's completely different so callisto
it's in it's a suitable land right so
it's not reference free it requires a
reference it requires a set of
transcripts
and then you
take those transcripts you um basically
make a database of their tamers
associated k-mers
and then you match k-mers in your sample
to those campers
so there are two there are some um very
strong differences between this
approaching callisto
um i could list one of them if you'd
like an hour later
and to which extent you know you get a
better sound
spicing is versus ability to build the
hope
you know model as
you know okay it's the final transcript
yeah yeah so that seems to be
maybe a difficult year so it's
interesting thank you for asking a
question because my group is actually
focused on alternative splicing until
really we i i stepped back about a year
ago um
i would say this approach has i would
say more power to detect
alternative flights and precisely both
in its discovery power and also
i didn't have time to talk about here
but it's on the bio archive paper i'd be
happy to talk about it that we are able
to basically um i would say
improve and denoise the splice junctions
that can be derived from any rna-seq
data
so i think that's one of the really
exciting things to me is that actually i
think we'll improve the power of
alternative protection in single cells
but you still will have to have an
alignment to build that effect true okay
and so that's a critical point that i
skipped for time
for those kinds of alignments we both do
this algorithm denoises and reduces the
number of required grades by three
orders of magnitude okay thanks
thank you